if you want to become a property
investor you want to make money you want
to be rich do not trust the government
with their schemes and ideas and plans
because in my opinion the government's
agenda is that you will be poor you will
work a regular job and work 40 hours a
week for 40 years to retire on 40 of
what you couldn't afford to live on in
the first place so in this video I'm
going to be answering many questions
that I get on Instagram people message
me every day about a new government
scheme or idea which is going to help
them get on the property ladder and I'm
going to give you my thoughts and
opinions on some of these schemes and
then telling you what I would do instead
so first scheme is the help to buy
scheme which is where the government
help you buy property by giving you a
deposit where you only have to put in
five percent so in other words if you're
buying a house for 200 000 pounds you're
going to typically need about 20 deposit
which is going to be what 40 Grand you
can't afford that so the government say
you put five percent in and will match
the difference this is help to buy this
scheme sucks run a mile from it it's
riddled with red tape and floors and
clauses and one of them is that you have
to live in the property we have to get
this in our head British people that
think that owning a house to live in is
a really good first step it's not it's a
terrible step if you own a house and you
live in it that house is not making you
any money and now you've got a big
mortgage and that mortgage is debt and
it's not good debt it's bad debt because
you have to physically pay it off
yourself because good debt is where you
have debt but it's making you money
owning a house that you live in is not
making you any money if anything it's
just making you a slave because now it's
like I definitely can't quit my job now
because I've got a mortgage drama net
and the government's agenda and most of
their schemes are around you buying a
house that you live in so now you're
riddled in debt also it only applies for
new build properties what happens when
you buy a new build property it drops in
10 when you buy it why because when it's
new and shiny it's more expensive so
they're loaning you money to buy a new
shiny house that you have to live in
that's a liability not an asset it drops
in value as soon as you buy it and now
your mortgage is more than the value of
the house so you're minus and trap
living in the house it sucks next shared
ownership shared ownership also sucks
that's where you buy a house but you
only buy a part of the house and you
rent the other part and it's really
difficult to get out of these schemes
because you can't sell on the how
how can you sell something where you
only own path now you've got a mortgage
and rent and it's always leasehold
properties so it just sucks don't do
shared ownership don't do help to buy
right to buy right to buy is something
that was bought in by Margaret Thatcher
they're already abolishing it in parts
of the UK and it's where if you've lived
in a council house for a very long time
you get you have a discount where you
have the right to buy it at a discount
this is a great thing you have the right
to buy
get in and get in now also let's say you
have right to buy it 30 discounted you
can actually use the discount as the
deposit not many people know this so I
like that scheme lifetime Isis I hate
lifetime answers suck that's where you
save up money to buy a house and the
government gives you 25 on top of what
you've saved anyway I think that sounds
great well no it's not it sucks first
way is it sucks is because you have to
buy a house to live in again everything
points you in the path
where the government want you to go
which is go to school be a good boy get
good grades get a job buy a house work
hard pay off the mortgage get a pension
and then retire at 67. everything points
you in that direction that's the ladder
they want you to climb and that ladder
doesn't work if you climb to the top of
that ladder by the time you get to the
top you'll realize that you climbed the
wrong ladder also you can't save more
than five grand a year so
psychologically it messes you up because
if you're saving for a house and the
government say save in a nicer and we'll
match 25 and you're like oh that sounds
great they're going to top it up by 25
so if I saved 10 grand they're going to
give me two and a half Grand towards the
house brilliant but then they tell you
that you can't put more than five grand
a year in it what happens what happens
is you it sucks you out now because now
you're thinking well how much do I need
to buy a house 50 Grand 100 Grand so now
you're thinking okay it's going to be
10 years before I can buy a house so in
your mind for the next 10 years you're
not even a homeowner you're living with
your parents you're playing on the
PlayStation this is the type of Reason
these Isis why people are getting pushed
back and back and back adolescence stage
young adult stage it's ridiculous so
those schemes don't like them if the
government are offering you a scheme you
should usually run a mile what should
you do instead because I'm not just
going to and moan about how bad
the government schemes are what should
you do instead you should create your
own schemes purchase lease option
agreement that is a brilliant scheme and
that is a way a method of buying a house
which the government are not involved
with where you can buy a house now you
pay for it later but you agree with the
owner rent to rent where you control a
property and rent it out for a higher
amount and you benefit from the month
for cash flow you're not owning anything
but you're controlling something and
making cash flow freedom freedom is what
we want all the other schemes the
government they're a rope around your
neck find private investors your parents
your family people that you know and
learn how to invest the money privately
and smart learn how to recycle the money
through Buy refurbished Finance buy a
house for 100 grand spend 50 Grand on it
and then refinance it at 200 Grand and
pull all the money back out and use
someone else's money to do it and
snowball your portfolio so there's many
things that you can do where the
government aren't involved which are
very smart and the funny thing is the
government and the media will bash these
Concepts the media will talk about how
rent to rents are really risky and
they're really bad no they're not
they're brilliant they just want you to
be a slave so if you want to learn the
creative strategies how you can actually
become financially independent and
successful without relying on the
government then join me at the property
investors crash course is one pound and
it all starts with the crash course so I
hope to see you there I'll leave a link
in the description let's spend the day
together it's one pound all across the
UK get booked let's work together let's
grow your portfolio let's do it now
thank you